herr hier leute
hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und willkommen zu einem neuen video dem
ersten video in 2020 ich hoffe ihr seid
alle super toll und gesund reingerutscht
dass es euch gut geht und ihr ein
lächeln auf ihrem gesicht treibt
[Musik]
ich halte ja nicht so viel von vorsätzen
beziehungsweise bin ich jetzt nicht der
mensch der sich die meisten vorsätze
macht weil ich in der vergangenheit auch
gelernt habe ich halt mich jetzt nicht
so sehr dran aber wovon ich bin total
großer fan bin sind diese 30 tage
challenges auf youtube und ich dachte
mir welcher monat passt denn besser als
so eine lebensverändernde geschichte wie
sport als für den januar
und letztes jahr bin ich schon ins
fitnessstudio gegangen ich mag
fitnessstudios ich mag auch mein
fitnessstudio aber man macht meistens so
drei wochen am stück mega viel sport und
dann fängt an sich die faulheit wieder
einzuschleichen und dann lässt du einmal
ausfallen und dann lässt du ein zweites
mal ausfallen
und plötzlich gehst du nicht jeden
zweiten tag sondern nur noch zweimal die
woche und dann gehst du nur noch einmal
die woche und dann also auch gemerkt
dass to [ __ ] das sondern geht es einfach
gar nicht mehr
und weil fitness stunde sind ganz viel
geld verbunden sind wollte ich das mal
so ein bisschen umswitchen und dachte
mir
moment mal timo hat sich doch diese via
brille geholt und warte mal da gibts
doch so ein spiel das heißt bizerba
das total spaß macht und man fängt voll
an zu schwitzen bei diesem spiel und man
könnte es ewig spielen also warum mache
ich das nicht einfach zu meinem workout
ich verbringe ich schon genug zeit zu
hause jetzt mache ich auch noch sport zu
hause ja das ist der plan 30 tage lang
jeden tag mindestens eine halbe stunde
bis eine stunde bizerba spielen wenn ich
mir das jetzt so vorstellt kann ist gar
nicht fehlen weil die selber so
unglaublich viel spaß macht und ich
fange jetzt mit diesem video an
ich werde mich jetzt messen wiegen und
dann schon mal die erste runde beat
selber spielen und euch auch zeigen was
bizerba überhaupt ist ich erzähle die
ganze zeit von und viele von euch wissen
gar nicht was es ist also ich will ne
coole beats elfer transition das ist
bizerba gerät bei bizerba hat man zwei
schwerter in der hand und dann macht man
damit blöcke kaputt das macht mega viel
spaß es macht mir viel spaß leute ist
macht es es macht so viel spaß ziemlich
jetzt mal um in sachen in denen ich
besser mich messen kann und falls sich
jetzt an dieser stelle gefragt habt aber
vanessa warum machst du das denn
überhaupt das ist doch perfekt aus dank
an dieser stelle ich habe über
weihnachten und auch davor ich habe
einfach viele kilos zugenommen und dafür
ist auch weihnacht noch irgendwie da man
soll futtern und sich gut gehen lassen
aber ich dachte mir jetzt nicht ich
möchte jetzt wieder in den spiegel
gucken sagen mama ja wie misst man sich
denn jetzt schlimme ist dass kamera
immer noch dicker macht obwohl ich kann
schon sagen das ist schon die wahrheit
hier
die plaut sich hier vorne gute hüften
habe ich gekriegt aber ich merke auch
echt an den oberschenkeln meine hosen
und an den
auch meine hosen passen einfach nicht
mehr
und das ist so deprimierend wenn man
einen schrank voller schöner hosen hat
und immer nur diese zwei trägt die halt
am größten sind frauen mit dem brust 5
90 zentimeter hoch steht
heute ist der zweite januar trick hat
mich ein bisschen dass es nicht im
ersten begonnen habe aber auch die macht
an seinen arm macht man ganz hält man
sein arm entspannt ja nicht anspannen
oder so für dieses spiel dieser heiße
draht diese locker halten 29 ist gut es
ist schlecht
29 zentimeter ich schreibe mir meine
maße auf weil gewicht auf einer waage
nicht so viel aussagekraft hat sein du
kannst ja auch an muskelmasse dazu
gewonnen haben und dann wie zeitlich
weniger aber bis trotzdem lang 79 an der
taille hat sagten der bauch über 90 cm
104 cm oberschenkels innenseite muss
auch welche pixel städte leben er ist
kann er nicht ähnlich schnellen 1
die dickste 57 zentimeter
so und jetzt als letztes haben wir auch
eine wahre unterschenkel 36 cm
na das sind doch schon mal zahlen auf
meinem handy jetzt kommt das wovor ich
ein bisschen mehr angst habe was sagt
die waage um 19 uhr
[Musik]
oh mein gott also ich meine ich war in
meinem leben schon mal schwerer gewicht
66,3 kilogramm
ziel 56 kilogramm feuerwerk was ich denn
eigentlich liegen möchte und ich dachte
mir so 55 bis 58 kilogramm und jetzt wo
ich sehe dass sich 66 kilo wiege würde
ich schon gerne zehn kilo abnehmen ich
weiß das wird jetzt nicht in 30 tagen
beats immer funktionieren aber
vielleicht wenigstens so
wie kann man in einem monat abnehmen wie
viel kann man ein dass meine freunde er
seine sehr oft gestellte frage vorwoche
sollte man nicht mehr als ein kilogramm
abnehmen
dies entspricht 4 kilogramm im monat gut
zu schaffen ist ließ durch gesunde
ernährung und sport klar wenn ich jetzt
krasse fitness kurse besuchen würde
würde es vielleicht noch ein bisschen
schneller gehen und bizerba ist jetzt
nicht der perfekte weg um schnell und
gesund abzunehmen
aber es ist ein cooles experiment also
leute lasst die erste bizerba session
beginnt übrigens dass videos nicht
gesponsert so redezeit bereit eine
brille aufsetzen guardian erstellen live
übertragen
da kann man gleich eis schweben krass
wir beginnen mit unserem ersten zorn
ich kann ja jetzt die gema musik nicht
benutze das heißt ich muss erstmal so
handelt dollar bildung klaut
ich spiele erst mal auf hart weil so gut
bin ich auch noch nicht so jetzt ins
o2-netz städter und dann macht ihr nur
gesagt
man kann es ein sommer folge lang bei
oder man geht nicht hin mit
[Musik]
das sind so was macht man sich training
lediglich ich habe jeden getroffen
ich versuche einfach nochmal das gleich
auf expert das kriege ich hier nicht man
muss es schaffen
okay aber es ist klar dass so einfach
die paypal das geht
[Musik]
wow
hallo ich habe mal kurz mein training
einstellen was meint ihr training cross
training meint ein koreanisch
[Musik]
barbara danke danke dem highscore
schluck wasser
das gute ist man weiß immer wie lange
und jugend macht
[Musik]
es gibt noch viel für euch zu tun
jeder wird hier zum man sogar to the
moon
ich bin ich gestorben etwa für die
agrana musste shake shake shake ching
ching kuo
danke dass die kamera noch läuft das war
so peinlich gewesen wenn die kamera
jetzt nicht mehr gelaufen hätte es sie
die wiederwahl danach aussieht 36
minuten sport gemacht 316 kalorien
verbrannt alle drei ziele erreicht
weshalb du hast alle seiner heutigen
aktivitäten ziele erreicht okay das war
tag 1 ich kann mir vorstellen dass jetzt
die nächsten 30 tage weiter zu machen
es ist halt wie spielen also ich hab bis
zu 45 minuten trainiert und ja natürlich
gibst du songs dazwischen da macht man
halt nur er so ein bisschen links aber
bleibt trotzdem in bewegung am meisten
bin ich darauf gespannt was es für
auswirkungen in dieser region haben wird
weil ich meine arme ultra viel bewege
aber natürlich den unteren teil nicht so
sehr ich versuche mal in die hocke zu
gehen
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
ich weiß nicht genau was dieses video
ist sie uns das nicht nur wieder und
bleibt sauber und bis dann